imagine you know all the thousands of
miles of coast on the west coast this
was the one little spot where african
americans could come and get into the
water
for dwayne yellow feather shepherd the
story of bruce's beach isn't just family
history but the story of a century of
shame for america the resort owned and
operated by willa and charles bruce was
a rarity at a time of racial segregation
the campaign of harassment and violence
to drive them out was not nor to the
seizure of their land ever since bruce's
beach has stood as a landmark to
property taken from people of color how
significant then this moment the
governor of california signing
legislation paving the way for it to be
returned to the family
still though emotions are mixed well
first of all it's uh one of anger of
what happened to my people at that time
they were traumatized by terrorists
who just didn't want them to be
uh at peace only only for the only for
the color of their skin
uh but then again now i'm very elated
you know people stepped up you know they
saw the wrong that was done it went
across genders and went across the race
it went across class and everybody
overwhelmingly supported our people
because this was just an injustice that
should not have been done in the name of
the law
we're at a point where it's like enough
is enough
enough is enough we're not going to be
docile it was kevon ward who led the
campaign over bruce's beach she's now
fighting for dozens of other families
seeking reparations for land taken
across america how many more there are
is anyone's guess
the scale is massive i mean think about
it we have 100 claims so far so if you
have
legal unjust practices in the past
in nearly every state
then i would have you really think about
like think about anybody think about
what do you think that number would be
right they left because
they were threatened
their lives were threatened their
children's lives were threatened and
this country has done nothing about that
it's time now
so is america at last confronting this
chapter of its history
you can't have significant moves to
change unless
there is a systemic
thing that goes on
this particular event
is
something that makes me have
optimism but progress it's a series of
things that happen maybe it'll make
people
be better people
but it's all something that we'll have
to wait and see we won't be able to tell
that uh
overnight
bruce's beach sits in one of the most
exclusive neighborhoods in america where
the average house price runs into the
millions wealth denied the bruce family
for a hundred years and even now there
are legal attempts to prevent it being
returned to the family that's uh the
story of america isn't it you know that
uh no matter what you know it's uh uh
these ex-slaves are not
uh uh entitled to anything you know
we've taken it you know we've won it we
conquered the people that were here we
murdered them we stole their land we
brought people here and enslaved them
and these are rx slaves and they don't
deserve anything
that's their attitude
greg milam sky news manhattan beach in
california